- You were saying about
mother's day gifts.
- Yeah.
- Cooper and I, and it came
from my mother who had a
very silly sense of humor.
- [Kelly] Oh, I love it.
- And loved pranks off camera.
Give each other really silly gifts.
Like it's always a mug
that says something.
I have one that says
that he got me that says I'm
a blanking ray of sunshine.
(Kelly laughs)
But I brought one of my
favorite gifts from him for you.
Yes, this was actually my
Valentine's day gift this year.
- What is it?
Wait, this is your Valentine.
(screams)
Oh God.
- (laughs)
Oh man.
Aw man.
(claps)
(laughs)
- That was my Valentine's
day gift from my son.
- I am gonna show my son this footage
and he is gonna love you so much.
- Yeah.
- Cause he tries to scare me all the time
and it's always with spiders.
- Yeah, but by the way, and I got the box
and he kept going, did Amazon deliver yet?
I'm like, no, no.
He's like, oh, call me as soon as they do.
So I'm like, okay, I'm opening it.
And I do it.
- I love that.
- And I was doing like,
why can't I open it?
I did it, I shrieked, I dropped the phone
and then put it on my assistant's desk.
- Oh yeah.
And then you paid it forward.
- (laughs)